we know it's been hard for parents for
students student athletes it's been hard
as well they are waiting to learn
if they'll be able to get back into
action this school year
ccsd postponed sports programs citing
concerns over the coronavirus hector
mejia is live this morning where a
protest is planned on this
issue later on today hector good morning
good morning and it's planned for four
o'clock in the afternoon and it's about
to be a year since the pandemic closed
campuses and sports seasons that's been
weighing heavy on a lot of students
especially those who need sports
scholarships to help pay for college
yesterday we talked with tara paris who
represents the group
let our kids play they expect dozens of
parents to show up today and demand
ccsd to bring back sports seasons
perez is the mother of two student
athletes a junior and a senior
she believes keeping them at home is
doing more damage than kovit is
and as a mother she sees first hand how
these closures
are crushing student athletes if
school stayed closed children should
have the option to attend activities
and it would help curb the numbers as
well as keeping kids motivated and
focused on the economic loss from
scholarships
um my one of my kids is a senior and
he's having a hard time even
finding the roster spot he hasn't been
able to play this year or last year
and it's it's been damaging
i reached out to ccisd for comment
yesterday in a written statement
the district said it made the difficult
decision to cancel fall sports for the
current school year
the district added fall sports were
scheduled to resume in february of this
year after postponement
at the start of the school year due to
covid but they did not specify
when sports seasons could return here
across the valley for students at ccsd
reporting live hector mejia
8 news now